Israel boycotts the boycotters the New
York Times goes fully woke and we check
the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show oh man we have a lot to
get to today let's just jump right in so
the big story of the day continues to be
the reverberations the fallout from
Israel rejecting the request to visit by
rashida to leave and Ilhan Omar to
anti-semitic members of Congress now
this is being completely miss portrayed
by the media shock of shocks I mean the
same media that pretends that every time
Hamas organizes a terrorist attempt on
the Israeli border and then Israel has
to shoot people attempting to invade its
country that Israel is the aggressor
that same media that routinely defends
the Palestinian Authority which is a
terrorist entity which funds terrorists
which names streets after terrorists
that that same media that champions
those folks that they are actually
championing Ilhan Omar and Rasheed ously
I can't believe it I just can't believe
it wasn't the media bias against Israel
goes back 30 40 years now I'm old enough
to remember back in the 1990s when my
parents cancelled their membership to
the LA Times because the LA Times had
run a photo on the front page suggesting
that a picture of an Israeli member of
the IDF protecting a Jew from being
beaten by Arab Muslims in Israel was
actually a picture of an Israeli member
of the military beating an Arab Muslim
in in Israel they they canceled the
membership to the LA Times over this the
media bias against Israel is
long-standing and it is not abated in
any way shape or form so the media
coverage naturally of the Ilhan Omar
Rasheeda Talib fake visit to Israel is
similarly egregious all the headlines
are Israel rent checks American Congress
people and the members of the media are
also buying the line put out there by
two Leoben Omar that Israel is rejecting
them because they are Muslim which is
eminently untrue and insane to boot
20% of Israel's population is Muslim
there are Arab Muslim parties sitting in
the Knesset right now members of those
parties have called for the destruction
of the State of Israel but because those
members of the party happen to be
Israeli Arab citizens they are free to
say whatever they want
there are Israeli Arab members of the
not only of the Knesset but of the
Israeli Supreme Court so all of this
talk about Israel is wildly
discriminatory against Muslim Arabic is
an official language in Israel Israel
has ruled off
it's for Jews prayer on the Temple Mount
the holiest site in Judaism you have to
have a special armed guard to go up on
the holiest site in Judaism controlled
by Israel in order to pray up there out
of respect for the Islamic walk when
there are riots up there every year or
so the Israelis basically protect the
right of view of the Muslim population
on top of the Temple Mount to riot lead
the Islamic walk has been destroying
historic artifacts up there and the
Israeli government has been doing
nothing about it
the notion that Israel doesn't tolerate
dissent is obviously insane the only
person the only people who could believe
that our people who have never been to
Israel or watched Israeli media coverage
Haaretz
which is a major Israeli newspaper is
not even comparable to the New York
Times right Haaretz is coverage of
Israel is more akin to al-jazeera than
it is to the New York Times and that is
a major Israeli newspaper so this notion
that Israel can't tolerate criticism or
that Israel is discriminating against
Muslims is sheer absolute nonsense and
yet that is the way the media is
portraying Israel's rejection of
Rashidah Talib and Ilhan Omar in reality
the reason they are rejecting rashida to
leave in omaha omar is it is against
israeli law for israel to allow people
into the country who seek to destroy the
country through boycott divestment and
sanctions that is a movement that was
started by terrorist sympathizers who
openly wish to see Israel wiped from the
map their idea is that if they can get
the world community to leverage economic
sanctions against Israel then Israel
will be greatly weakened and they've
made no secret of this the leaders of
the BDS movement have made no secret of
the fact that they are not interested in
forcing Israel to a negotiated peace
with terrorists instead what they are
interested in is Israel not being on the
map and retreated to leave but no
Hanauma are part of that movement both
of them are anti-semitic Rasheeda Talib
has used publicly the dual loyalty smear
Rasheeda Talib is hung out with Hamas
sympathizers with Hezbollah sympathizers
with terrorists sympathizers for large
swathes of her career I mean going back
to January there was a report in The
Times of Israel about Talib opposing
with a Hezbollah backing anti-israel
activist named Abbas Hamidah who
actually painted a picture of her in
front of the Capitol building wearing
the the Palestinian scarf the
Palestinian pride scarf according to The
Times of Israel back in January an
anti-israel extremist who has a right to
return advocacy group
which would call for the importation of
every Palestinian into Israel as
citizens which would of course destroyed
the Jewish nature of the state and
destroy the democracy attended a Detroit
swearing-in reception and dinner party
for freshman Rasheeda Talib where he
posed with her for a photograph that he
tweeted he said I was honored to be a
congresswoman to lead swearing-in
ceremony in Detroit and private dinner
afterward with the entire family friends
and activists across the country in the
picture commie that is holding a
painting of Talib in front of the US
Capitol while she's wearing a tub a
traditional Palestinian gown that she
wore during her swearing-in on Capitol
Hill coming as social media presence is
noteworthy for its virulence attack on
the Jewish state he has tweeted things
like criminal Zionism will eventually
die just like Nazism no racist and
supremacist political ideology should
maintain itself Israel does not have a
right to exist this is a person posing
with Rasheeda Talib at her inauguration
at her swearing-in and then she also
posed with a second terrorist supporter
this is according to Stephen Emerson IPT
News two months after that in March she
posed with nader cello gel a Palestinian
activist who last year mourned the death
of a terrorist who led a shooting attack
that murdered a rabbi so Rasheeda Talib
has not been particularly shy about her
associations neither has Ilhan Omar and
they weren't being very shy about their
associations on this particular trip
either because as it turns out the
Israeli government and I've spoken
members of the Israeli government
members the Trump administration about
all this the Israeli government was
fully prepared to let Omar until he
visit and then they saw their itinerary
and the Israeli government said no this
is not a thing that's going to happen
why because the itinerary first of all
said nothing about even visiting Israel
wasn't about visiting Israel it was
about visiting quote unquote Palestine
okay and when they said visiting
Palestine they didn't mean visiting
Ramallah the first day is in Jerusalem
so Jerusalem according to Omar and Talib
is Palestinian territory do you think
Israel would stand for that why should
they stand for that not only that the
groups that Omar and Talib were going on
this trip with are openly anti-semitic
terrorists supporting groups so why
would Israel let these people in I mean
it's the fault of their constituents in
the United States they're in Congress
that's not Israel's fault and as we will
see
the United States actually has a record
of barring Israeli legislators from
entering the United States if they feel
they have terrorized this happened back
in 2012 so let's talk a little bit about
this trip okay because all of this is
just a giant PR setup for Omar and Talib
that's all this says the whole thing is
manipulative garbage on the part of both
Omar and Talib which became absolutely
clear today when we're sheeted to leave
made it clear that she hates the Jews
more than she loves her own grandmother
that is that is pretty obvious from her
behavior today we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about how
you do business so it is somewhat
important when you are when you are
doing business to be able to hand
somebody your business card how many
situations are you in where you reach
into your pocket you don't have the
business card you want or it turns out
that you went down to the local Kinkos
and printed off some cheap business
cards they don't look particularly good
well he actually need a nice business
card if you want to impress somebody
right off the bat your next big
opportunity is coming right now all it
takes to feel like you're ready to own
the now is ten bucks for just ten bucks
vistaprint gives you 500 personalized
cards with exactly the look that you
want that is a low price to make a
lasting impression and because you can
choose the colors fonts designs images
that means you can create something as
unique and compelling as your business
you don't really need more reasons to
choose vistaprint than that right I mean
it's inexpensive and you're getting the
business cards that you want but you can
also feel good knowing that vistaprint
uses only carefully selected inks and
responsibly sourced paper stocks and
your satisfaction is 100% guaranteed or
your money back and they will make it
right if there's any sort of mistake
vistaprint they want you to be able to
own the nail in any situation and that's
why listeners to the ben shapiro show
get 500 high-quality custom business
cards starting at nine bucks ninety nine
cents just go to vistaprint.com slash
shapiro for that awesome deal
that's vistaprint.com slash shapiro you
got five hundred custom business cards
on the nail vistaprint.com slash shapiro
alrighty so what exactly were these
illustrious Congress women these
anti-semetic congresswoman and notice by
the way media bias in its purest form
when Donald Trump says something that is
racially insensitive or xenophobic the
media rushed to call it racist which is
an editorial judgment they say this is a
racist comment and in fact when the New
York Times prints a headline after the
El Paso shooting Trump urges unity
versus racism people lose their minds
because you're not even allowed to
suggest
which is that he was urging unity
against racism in other words newspapers
will characterize what trump says the
way they see it right they'll call him a
racist because they feel the duty to do
so when we shooted Talib or el Han Omar
say something anti-semitic the first
move of the media is to ignore that and
pretend they are not saying anything
anti-semitic and the New York Times will
print headlines about them how they've
opened a conversation about Israeli
money on Capitol Hill or somesuch which
is what they did after Ilhan Omar
suggested that American support for
Israel is all about the Benjamins in any
case so what we're all Martin to lead
actually going to do in Israel as I say
their itinerary was labeled a trip to
Palestine which in and of itself
eliminates the Jewish state there is no
actual territory called Palestine it
does not legally exist there Palestinian
administered territories that are
disputed under international law and
that Israel claims ownership of both
historically as well as in terms of
winning the winning a war which they did
in 1967 as well as 1973 both wars
initiated by Israel's enemies well what
exactly was was on their itinerary well
apparently the office of the Prime
Minister of Israel has revealed that
Omar anslee had plans on meeting with
organizations during their visit that
have expressed support for terrorism
against the nation the officer the
office of Prime Minister Netanyahu
tweeted quote the itinerary of the two
Congresswomen reveals that the sole
purpose of their visit is to harm Israel
and increase incitement against it in
addition the organization that is
funding their trip is miffed ax which is
an avid supporter of BDS and among whose
members are those who have expressed
support for terrorism against Israel
okay so what is this miffed a group okay
that's a non-governmental organization
that is extremely anti-semitic okay they
have ties to terrorist sympathizers they
have falsely accused Jews of using the
blood of Christians in the Jewish
Passover miffed ah--this group that
these women were traveling with has also
reportedly praised suicide bombers and
deems terrorists as being national
heroes one of the most stunning findings
on the group cording to Ryan's Vedra at
Daily wire is that they have on their
website promoted content from a neo-nazi
organization which itself promotes
anti-semitic conspiracy theories that
Jews control the media the author of the
article in question that was promoted on
the mythity website is the research
staff of national Vanguard books which
is a neo now
the organization according to the
Southern Poverty Law Center and they
actually put out a piece on their
website talking about the evils of
miscegenation I mean it's unbelievable a
closer look at the travel itinerary for
Omar and sleep shows they also plan on
meeting with additional extremist
organizations including the defense for
Children international Palestine which
has ties to terrorism NGO monitor
reports that dcpip leads the campaign
exploiting children to promote
demonization of Israel and is linked to
the PFLP terror group many of its
allegations are false and part of
attempts to smear Israel with
allegations of war crimes and promote
BDS several past and current dcpip board
members and employees have apparent ties
to the Popular Front for the Liberation
of Palestine which is a designated
terror organization by the US EU Canada
as well as Israel and they support BDS
which Nancy Pelosi called like two
months ago anti-semitic Seth Mantell of
Washington Examiner magazine he tweeted
one reason you won't see coverage of the
organization funding to leave an Omar's
trip is that it would undermine the
narrative this is about criticism of
Israeli policy it shows the true face of
BDS blood libels Nazi screeds
celebration of terrorists and naturally
he's right the media have completely
ignored all of this
okay so President Trump had suggested
that Israel bar them and Trump is doing
this for his own political reasons one
of those reasons is that President Trump
would like to make Ilhan Omar and
Rashida to leave the faces of the
Democratic Party he wants to force
Pelosi and stiney Hoyer and Chuck
Schumer to all get behind the most
radical members of the Democratic Party
so that he can run against them and it's
not a bad domestic political strategy so
there is some strategy to it it's also
true that Trump happens to be morally
right when he says that Israel shouldn't
let these people in okay the so I'll
talk a little bit about the strategy
here in a second whether it benefits
Israel whether Israel did the
politically right thing in barring these
women I think that the case is getting
stronger that they did actually as these
women expose their own agenda but
president Trump had made the very strong
case that Israel shouldn't let these
people that people are now in the United
States saying how dare he say something
like really really okay if you're a
Democrat and you went out there and
suggested that Mexico shouldn't let
Trump in do you think there'd be any
hubbub at all about that
like really on the part of the media
would that be considered unpatriotic if
some Democrat suggested that Steve King
should be barred from entry to for
example in African nation do you think
that anybody in media or government
would think that this was an element of
treason and here's Trump saying Israel
shouldn't have to let in people who want
to destroy it look at what they've said
if I ever said it it would be it would
be a horrible it would be a horrible
month to put it mildly so the things
that they've said Omar to leave what
they've said is disgraceful so I can't
imagine why Israel would let them in but
if they want to let them in they can but
I can't imagine why they were doing okay
and then he he continued along those
lines he said they said some of the
worst things about Israel of course
everything he is saying here's a hundred
percent true that if Israel allowed them
to come in for the normal reasons other
than those reasons I really believe that
it would be a terrible thing for Israel
I think it would show a terrible sign
they want to do boycotts they said
horrible things about Jewish people they
said horrible things about Israel and
Israelis I think would be a terrible
thing frankly for Israel to let these
two people who speak so badly about
Israel come in and the media is
responsive how dare Trump again if this
were Barack Obama is president talking
about Steve King visiting Africa no one
would think that that was a bad thing
right or if you'd said that about Donald
Trump visiting Mexico right then nobody
would think that that was a bad thing
particularly in the media in one second
I'm gonna get to what the Prime Minister
of Israel has to say about all of us it
is obvious what the agenda was from the
start today Rasheed Talib totally
exposed the agenda because she is not
only a terrible person who believes
terrible things she's also a fool I'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about how hard it is to make
your staff great I mean you have a
business and you may be hired some
people off the street you hired people
by recommendation and now maybe you're
unsatisfied with their work or maybe you
just want to expand your business and
find some new great people well the best
way to do that is to go to zip recruiter
we use zip recruiter here at the daily
wear it's how we found all of our
producers except for Nick go check out
zip Roker com
daily wire and you too can find great
employees except for necks impro critter
sends your job posting
to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one spotlights the top
candidates scene you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective at
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter an equality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiters comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter com slash Dai
ly WI re zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire make sure that your
staff is the best that it can be and get
great new employees at zip recruiters
comm slash daily wire they make it super
simple zip recruiters comm slash daily
wear okay so Prime Minister Netanyahu
put out this statement no country in the
world respects America and the American
Congress more than the State of Israel
as a free and vibrant democracy Israel
is open to critics and criticism with
one exception Israeli law prohibits the
entry into Israel of those who call for
and work to impose boycotts on Israel as
do other democracies that prohibit the
entry of people who seek to harm the
country in fact in the past the US did
this to an Israeli member of Knesset as
well as two other public figures from
around the world this is true in 2012
the Obama administration barred a member
of Knesset nimbin re and they did so
because he was associated with the
Kahana high party which is considered a
terrorist organization in the United
States the Kaka party he was no longer
in the Kok party but his past with the
Kok party led the United States to bar
him from entry an entire Israeli
delegation then canceled its trip this
was not considered a big deal at the
time because countries have rules Prime
Minister of Israel continues Congress
women to leave in omar are leading
activists in promoting the legislation
of boycotts against israel in the
american congress only a few days ago we
received their itinerary for their visit
in israel which revealed that they plan
to visit
whose sole objective is to strengthen
the boycott against us and denied
Israel's legitimacy for instance they
listed the destination of their trip as
palestine and not israel and unlike all
Democratic and Republican members of
Congress who have visited Israel they
did not request to meet any Israeli
officials either from the government or
the opposition a week ago Israel warmly
welcomed some 70 Democratic and
Republican members of Congress who
expressed broad bipartisan support for
Israel which
also demonstrated a month ago in a
resounding bipartisan vote against PDS
in Congress however the itinerary of the
two Congress women reveals the sole
purpose of their visit is to harm Israel
and increase incitement against it in
addition the organization funding their
trip is miffed ax which is an avid
supporter of BDS and among whose members
are those who have expressed support for
terrorism against Israel therefore the
Minister of Interior has decided not to
allow their visit and I as Prime
Minister support his decision
nonetheless if congresswoman Talib
submits a humanitarian request to visit
her relatives the Minister of Interior
has announced that he will consider her
request on the condition that she
pledges not to act to promote boycotts
against Israel during her visit and all
of that is reasonable the US ambassador
to Israel is David Friedman and he
released his own statement supporting
Israel the statement says the United
States supports and respects the
decision of the government of Israel to
deny entry to the Talib Omar delegation
the BDS movement against Israel is not
free speech it is no less than economic
warfare designed to deal with JIT amide
and ultimately destroy the Jewish state
Israel properly has enacted laws to bar
entry of BDS activists under those
circumstances present here and it has
every right to protect its borders
against those activists in the same
manner as it would bar entrance with
more conventional weapons initially
Israel had indicated it would accept the
Talib Omar delegation and used their
visit as an opportunity to engage with
and educate the delegation members with
regard to Israel's vibrant and robust
democracy its religious tolerance and
ethnic diversity
unfortunately the itinerary of the Talib
Omar delegation leaves no room for that
opportunity this trip pure and simple is
nothing more than an effort to fuel the
BDS engine that congresswoman to leave
an Omar so vigorously support like the
United States Israel is a nation of laws
we support Israel's application of its
laws in this case
hey that statement is entirely just and
proper okay so
Ilhan Omar then responds with a
completely dishonest statement which is
a giant shock knowing Ilhan Omar's
history as a congressperson and before
quote it is an affront that Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu under
pressure from President Trump with deny
entry to representatives of the US
government Trump's Muslim ban is what
Israel is implementing hey this is this
is there such sheer nonsense built into
this line it's pretty incredible from
some Muslim man no Muslim ban has ever
been enforced in the United States nor
should it he traveled
involves seven countries only five of
which are majority Muslim they're
50-plus majority Muslim countries on
planet Earth most of them the vast
majority of nearly all of them are not
covered by the travel ban Israel is not
implementing a Muslim ban they're
implementing au ban right they're
banning Omar and Talib not because of
their muslim heritage not because of
their religion but because they want to
destroy the State of Israel but illa Han
Omar's a liar so she lies Trump's Muslim
ban is what Israel is implementing this
time against - duly elected members of
Congress denying entry into Israel not
only limits our ability to learn from
Israelis but also to enter the
Palestinian territories okay um you had
no intention of learning from Israelis
we saw your itinerary so you're a liar
sadly she says this is not a surprise
given the public positions of Prime
Minister Netanyahu who has consistently
resisted peace efforts two years ago he
offered to come to the table with
Mahmoud Abbas and negotiate without
preconditions it turns out it's very
difficult to negotiate with people who
want to murder you restricted freedom of
movement of Palestinians that's true
because every time the security fence is
opened up people tried to commit acts of
terrorism limited public knowledge of
the brutal realities of the occupation
yeah why don't you read hearts once in a
while and align himself with
Islamophobes like Donald Trump that's of
course is great sin as a member of the
House Committee on Foreign Affairs it is
my job to conduct oversight of foreign
aid from the United States of America
this does bring up a point Nancy Pelosi
by putting this this ideologically
radical nasty human being on the House
Committee on Foreign Affairs committed a
great sin against the American people
because this lady should not be anywhere
near the levers of power when it comes
to the delegation of foreign aid there
can be good arguments to be made about
foreign aid she is not gonna make them
this is not an honest person trying to
push the priorities of the United States
abroad in terms of human rights because
this is the same person who says we
shouldn't sanction Venezuela or Russia
or China or Iran but we should sanction
Israel this is not a good-faith human
being by the way this isn't it this is
on Nancy Pelosi and it's also one's head
to members of Congress for the Democrats
who had to sign off on this
congressional delegation visiting using
an NGO that has to be signed off on by
party leadership okay that is her
statement okay and her statement is a
bunch of crap how do we know that her
statement is a bunch of crap well one of
the ways that we know that Hurst
is a bunch of crap is because Rasheeda
Talib then decided that she was going to
fulfill that request she put out a bunch
of tweets about how she really really
wanted to visit her city no one knows
what that means
I don't know what that term means but
apparently that refers to her
grandmother and how she really really
wanted to visit her grandmother who
lives in Judea and Sumeria lives in the
West Bank and it is very important for
her to visit her dying grandmother and
in fact she issued a letter she issued a
letter to the to aria Terry whose
Minister of the Interior in Israel and
here is her letter quote Minister Gerry
I would like to request admittance to
Israel in order to visit my relatives
and specifically my grandmother who was
in her 90s and lives in Bates or of
Fuuka this could be my last opportunity
to see her I will respect any
restrictions and will not promote
boycotts against Israel during my visit
so that was granted Israel said okay you
want to visit your grandmother that's
fine you just don't get to propagandize
on behalf of our destruction but you
want to visit grandma all you go for it
and then Rashid it Talib turned around
and said you know what screw it grandma
I know she's old if I don't see her
before she dies whatever if I don't get
to go there and crap on the Israelis and
the Jews while I'm there I'm not gonna
visit grandma this is really what she
said right so she tweets out my city
wanted to pick FIGS with me I broke down
reading this and worried every single
day after I won for my family safety my
cousin was texting me which photo of
Ilhan Omar and I they should put on a
welcoming poster when I heard the news I
couldn't tell her okay and then the
Israeli government came back and they
said I'm sure you want to come you can
come you just can't be a propagandist on
behalf of terrorism when Russia did tool
it was like no now I don't want to come
my city can go can go do whatever she
wants my take my city and do it my
grandma you know what I guess I don't
need to see her that much she tweeted
out when I won it gave the Palestinian
people hope that someone will finally
speak the truth about the inhumane
conditions I can't allow the State of
Israel to take away that light by
humiliating me and used my love for my
city to bow down to their oppressive and
racist policies so now the agenda is
exposed right this was never about
visiting grandmama this was never about
going and visiting my relatives in the
West Bank this was never about any of
that was about propagandizing that's
what this is all about which is why
Israel rejected her application to enter
in the first place it is
really amazing it is truly amazing that
receded to leave would expose herself
this way but again you give these folks
on the left enough rope and they will
hang themselves she followed that up
with another tweet silencing me and
treating me like a criminal is not what
she wants for me you've not been
silenced lady it seems like you get to
talk however much you want you just
don't get to go to Israel and use it as
backdrop for your propaganda
she said it would kill a piece of me
which piece would that be exactly like
your toe
what are you it seems like you're
getting a lot of media attention she
says I've decided that visiting my
grandmother under these oppressive
conditions stands against everything I
believe in fighting against racism
oppression and injustice also let's be
real grandma's kind of boring like
that's it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable huh sparred her from
visiting her grandma no Israel said you
can visit grandma you just not allowed
that hang out with terrorists while you
do it it was like nope grandmas on her
own what a delight what did too like
these folks are now in a second we'll
get to the Democratic response to all of
this what should they have said what
will they say was this a good strategy
by Israel get to that in one second
first you know when you're on the road
you look around lots of different kinds
of cars and you think to yourself okay
well if a car in my part breaks down
what if a part in my car breaks down
what exactly can I do about that
right if I go to an auto parts store
what are the chances they're gonna have
the exact part that I need for this
exact make and model of car and the
chances honestly they're not all that
good you're gonna have to get like an
off-brand not great piece or something
that is generic well instead what you
need to do is go to Rock Auto comm
they're a family business serving Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years go
to rock Auto comm and shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need and a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door the Rock auto comm catalog is super
easy to navigate quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
filter by brands specifications and
prices best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers they've got amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car is ever going to need
Rock Auto calm go to rockauto.com right
now
you see all the parts available to you
for your car or truck right shapiro in
there how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you again
Shapiro in there how did you hear about
his box so they know that we sent you
okay so as we have now found out
Rasheeda Talib cares much more about
slandering Israel than about visiting
City and about visiting her grandmother
hey it was all a bad faith effort from
the beginning it was all a bad faith
effort now the Democrats have responded
of course by defending Omar and Talib
and maybe that was the intent for
president Trump maybe the intent for
President Trump was get the Democrats to
defend Omar and Talib so we can point to
them and show how radical they are now I
don't think they needed to do this
frankly like I think that I think that
if Trump wanted to label the squad the
leadership of the house that's already
on the board right I mean think people
already kind of get that especially
because the squad is extraordinarily
loud
I mean AOC again being a liar she
tweeted out members of Congress are
frequently asked to visit Israel to see
things for ourselves but Netanyahu
choosing to ban the only two Muslim
women in Congress from entering tells
the u.s. that only some Americans are
welcome to Israel not all again is a lie
they're not banning them because they're
Muslim the banning them because they are
hanging out with terror activists that
would be it Trump is exported his
bigotry says aoc and making matters
worse huh what strength what a pillar of
genius she is and as I say I think that
Trump's strategy here is to make the
squad the face of the Democratic Party
that does come with some dangers danger
number one is that the Democratic Party
could then win and then the squad is in
charge that's actually a scary thought
right you don't actually want the
Democratic Party to rally around the
nasty discriminatory gross ideology of
the squad Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda Talib
in particular so it's a dangerous game
to elevate those people to a position of
prominence rather than trying to force
Democrats to separate off of them which
probably is what would have happened by
the way Omar and Talib probably would
have gone they would have propagandized
that propaganda would have become a
serious subject of controversy among the
intelligentsia but it would be obvious
that was propaganda and then Trump could
go to all the Democrats and say guys you
really ok with this sort of
propagandizing on behalf of terror
everything I told you before about the
terror supporting groups with whom Omar
and Talib are associated that could have
been made front-page news by President
Trump right he could have done that
after they went there the pre-emptive
bar forces a lot of Democrats to back
Omar in to lead when the
might not necessarily otherwise have
done so anyway this is what the
Democrats do now what the Democrats
should do here right is they should say
listen Israel has rules they're applying
their rules Omar and Talib have have
beliefs that are way out of the
Democratic mainstream which is why we
voted against those beliefs instead but
but and by the way I think that
Republicans would do that with Steve
King for example right if Steve King had
wanted to plan a trip to Mexico and the
Mexican government said not not
interested I think a lot of Republicans
would gone all right all right fair
enough but the Democrats are always
going to defend their own so joe biden
tweets out something truly disingenuous
quote i've always been a stalwart
supporter of Israel mm-hmm
not so much a vital partner that shares
our democratic values no democracy
should denied entry to visitors based on
the content of their ideas even ideas
they strongly object to and no leader of
the free world should encourage them to
do so okay that is a bunch of horse
manure in the United States bars entry
to a wide variety of people based on the
beliefs that they hold based on the
content of their ideas like if you come
here and you want to destroy the country
then you are not allowed in in fact even
if you don't want to destroy the country
you may not be allowed in in 2012 the
Obama administration banned a delegation
banned a delegation from Israel why
because there was a member named named
Ben re and Ben Michael ben-ari of the
National Union party they said that he
had ties to terror group called Kok and
the u.s. refused entry to him so Reuven
Rivlin who is the Speaker of the Knesset
announced that he would ban the entire
delegation of members of Knesset from
attending women's conference in
Washington in retaliation guess who was
vice president when the Obama
administration barred entry to the
United States for a sitting member of
the Israeli Parliament based on that
person's viewpoint and associations who
is the vice president oh yeah that was
Joe Biden so when he says no democracy
should deny entry to visitors based on
the contents of their ideas um yeah you
did you did that right you're you're the
administration you served under did that
and then you get Chuck Schumer's
response so Chuck Schumer similarly
suggested denying entry to members of
the US Congress is a sign of weakness
not strength it will only hurt the US
Israel relationship and support for
Israel in America well he said no
democratic society should fear an open
debate Israel does not fear an open
debate they are not going to import
people to hang out with terrorists
supporting groups many strong supporters
of Israel will be deeply disappointed in
this decision which the Israeli
government should reverse the question
is whether Omar and Talib should receive
special dispensation because they're
members of Congress when if they were
not members of Congress they would
certainly be barred Ariel Gold is a
Jewish woman who works for a code pink
and she was barred from entry to Israel
specifically because of her support for
boycott divestment and sanctions so if
she remember of Congress you should be
allowed in now is that how this works
again the Democrats are wrong here but
it is true that the strategy here by the
Israelis was probably destined to do
this his tiny warrior does the same
thing in Stanny Hoyer is the the House
Majority Whip and he similarly put out a
statement talking about how this was bad
he said the decision of the Israeli
government to deny entry to Israel by
two members of Congress is outrageous
regardless of their itinerary or their
views really so if they went there and
just said we're meeting with class and
we want to blow up the State of Israel
could Israel deny entry
according to Stinney Hoyer the answer is
no ted Lieu one of the dummer members of
the Democratic delegation he went even
further he accused the US ambassador to
Israel of dual loyalty he suggested that
that David Friedman who is the US
ambassador to Israel is actually loyal
to Israel not to the United States
ambassador Friedman the US ambassador
Israel actually I think he should resign
because he doesn't seem to understand
that his allegiance is to America not to
inform power he should be defending the
rights of Americans to travel to other
countries but the Ambassador was
basically saying what the President of
the United States his boss was saying
well I wish president Trump would resign
I don't think I do that but certainly I
can call on ambassador Friedman to
resign his allegiance again is to
America not to a foreign power and it's
to Constitution United States not to the
president okay so the fact is that his
allegiance is not really in question
okay the you can you can have allegiance
to the United States and also believe
that Israel has no duty to import terror
supporters onto its shores okay Ted Luth
until he tweeted the same thing and then
he and then he tweeted out it has been
brought to my attention my prior tweet
to the US ambassador in Israel raises
two
loyalty allegations that have
historically caused harm to the Jewish
community that's a legitimate concern
I'm therefore deleting the tweet yeah
it's a little late dude I mean it's
pretty obvious you said it twice on CNN
like we all know what meant so in terms
of strategy here's the problem
there is something beneficial to Israel
in having Democrats who are weak
supporters of Israel still be titular
supporters of Israel forcing them to
back Omar and to leave or putting them
in a position that makes it easy for
them to back Omar and Talib may bear
some negative fruit down the line when
Omar in talib gained more and more power
inside the Democratic caucus and when
Democrats make clear that they're going
to continue kowtow lying to them it is
it is opening a rift that doesn't
necessarily need to be able now maybe
that rift already exists it's been my
belief that since the Obama
administration the Democratic Party has
been moving radically anti-israel and
they continue to do so and that extends
all the way to Chuck Schumer and his
Democratic Party backing the Iran
nuclear deal with that said is it a good
strategic move I'm not sure it's a good
strategic move by Israel to borrow
Martin's believe I think there were
other ways of demonstrating what Omar
and Talib were doing on a moral level is
there any question that Israel has the
right to do this
no should they do this on a moral level
absolutely absolutely the only question
is logistics is it smart for Israel to
do it is it is a good PR for Israel to
do it again I think that the case is now
moving in Israel's direction given the
fact that receded to leave has basically
come out and explained that she doesn't
care about visiting her grandma at all
all she cares about is slandering the
State of Israel already in just a second
we're gonna get to a coverage shift over
at the New York Times that demonstrates
full scale the insanity of our
mainstream media and how it seems that
editorial is now in the control of a
bunch of woke interns from Wesleyan I'll
get to that in just a second first there
are only a few days left to purchase
tickets to our backstage live show it's
a special one-night only event next
Wednesday August 21st at the fantastic
terrorist theater in Long Beach
California I'll be there daily where God
king Jeremy Boren will be there Andrew
Clavin will be there
Michael moles will be there we'll all be
there alive right we won't be dead we'll
get into politics pop culture and
answering your questions from the
audience which is always the best part
tickets are available at Daley wire.com
slash backstage including our limited
VIP packages that guarantee premium
seating
photos meet and greets with each of us a
gift from me I'm shopping for it for you
right now and more they are selling fast
so head on over to Daly wire.com slash
backstage get yours
today it should be a blast I hope to see
you there next week also good news
getting the daily wire has somehow
managed to turn four years old that's
right we've survived I'm just as
surprised and thrilled as you are so our
employees who continue to be paid
incredibly you've spent almost 72
million hours listening to our podcasts
not you individually because you're not
gonna live that long but collectively
you spend 72 million hours listening to
our podcast which for me feels just like
listening to one episode of Michael
nolza show as a thank you to our fans we
are giving away one month of our premium
monthly subscription to anyone who uses
the code birthday that's right go check
it out right now you get one month free
of the premium monthly which is pretty
awesome that's right for this entire
month all of August as we celebrate this
magical milestone we are giving away a
free first month four new premium
monthly subscribers which is a great
deal again just use the code birthday
and come join the fun it's 13 months for
the price of 12
yay good stuff also our Sunday special
this week is fantastic okay so I've been
waiting to break the news to you but our
Sunday special this week which is
available to subscribers tomorrow early
is with wait for it
Piers Morgan who as it turns out to a
really nice dude can I get along great
so Piers Morgan and I had a great
conversation arranged on everything yeah
we did cover some gun control stuff in
this particular conversation I really
wanted to let piers kind of spill out
his own ideas on the subject since he
let me do the same on his show and and
you should check it out it really is
great here's a little bit of what it
sounded like at what point does the
safety and the health of a lot of people
get dictated to by a group of other
people it's a fundamental question for
the public health of the country and
treating guns like a public health issue
would be a really smart move for America
right
the conversation is really fantastic it
is not just I'm gun control the vast
majority of the conversation actually is
on other stuff some media it's on the
nature of celebrity it's on President
Trump he's good friends with President
Trump so there's a lot of insight and I
think you'll find it fascinating and
piers a good dude I mean one of the
beautiful things that I loved about
doing the Sunday special is I really do
get to hang out with people on the other
side of various Isles right people with
whom I disagree about a wide variety of
topics and it turns out when you're
trying to have a discussion with them
you can actually learn something from
them maybe they learn something from you
and so it's great about America I I feel
like it's dying right now but that's I
really enjoyed the Sunday special I
think people too also it is that
glorious time of the week when I give a
shout out to a daily water subscriber
today it's a Twitter user named Dustin
who clearly understands the reality of a
hard-working life in this pic
Dustin's glorious left his tears tumbler
takes a breather while sitting on a busy
waterway with huge commercial ships in
the background the caption reads out
you're working hard on a Sunday someone
has to pay the taxes for liberal
policies hashtag commercial diver
hashtag Salvage driving hashtag left his
tears tumblr that is more of a man than
I will ever be right there this this guy
yeah that about sums it up thanks for
the pick dust and stay safe down there
keep up the good work
see this is what America is about making
those choices to make your life better
make your family stronger this is good
stuff right here Thank You Dustin also I
hope that you are not actually a Russian
bot because your actual screen name is
Russian bot 0 3 3 1 at Twitter so if
you're a Russian bot sorry everybody but
if you're not I hope you're not a diver
for the Russian government ok so we will
get to more in just a second as I say
please go subscribe
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so meanwhile I have some brief bad news
apparently Greenland is not for sale
this is very disappointing president
Trump apparently was super interested in
buying Greenland this is according to
The Wall Street Journal and I was like
totally on board with this I would
honestly if he didn't want America to
buy Greenland I think yeah hey hey
murica I mean if we're gonna listen five
places right in a war were rich we got
something we got I mean sure we have
like 21 trillion dollars in debt but
we're rich you can't afford like a giant
iceberg it seems kind of fun and plus
eventually a lot of those icebergs will
melt that will be a that'll be a
waterway like a northern passage it'll
be it'll be really really important so
why not just buy Greenland I think that
was Trump's law also you could build a a
beautiful unbelievable hotel to make a
golf course right on the glacier
unbelievable is it it was a great idea
buying greenland sadly this has now been
quashed by the government of greenland
they say we are not for sale so it's war
then all right we will be sending over
ten of our finest honestly we should
just buy Hong Kong it seems like the
return on investment is better and the
people are very interested in getting
the hell away from Chinese governance so
maybe we can make that deal maybe maybe
as part of the closing of the tariff
deal with China we just buy Hong Kong
that seems like a good idea I felt I
needed to give you that update because I
was so enthusiastic yesterday on my
radio show about buying Greenland then
I'd feel bad if you went into the
weekend thinking that was still a
possibility meanwhile over at the New
York Times the woke have taken over it
is amazing very often these sorts of
ridiculous and Soros decisions that are
made I mean at these at these
organizations like the Atlantic to go
after Kevin Williamson or Business
Insider to go after to go after Daniela
Greenbaum like that those decisions are
usually not made by the editors those
decisions are being made by the interns
who get the coffee because very often
the editors out of a feeling of I need
to I need to care what my employees
think and if they're offended by
somebody then then we need to change our
editorial policy that's had a major
impact on how organizations run up to
and including the New York Times
according to the Washington Examiner
Dean Baquet the executive editor of the
New York Times said recently and after
the Mulla report the paper has to shift
the focus of its coverage from the Trump
Russia affair to the president's alleged
racism he says we built our newsroom to
cover one store
and we did it truly well now we have to
regroup and shift resources and emphasis
to take on a different story so in other
words the editorial coverage at the New
York Times the news coverage is being
dictated by narratives that the New York
Times left wants to push so it went from
Russia which was a giant fail for them
to Trump's a racist in no time flat and
they're gonna shift how the paper is
constituted in order to push that but
kept made the remarks at an employee
Town Hall on Monday our recording was
leaked to slate which published a
transcript on Thursday but ket explained
chapter one of the story of Donald Trump
not only for our newsroom but frankly
for our readers was did Donald Trump
have an untoward relationship with the
Russians and was there obstruction of
justice that was a really hard story by
the way let's not forget that we set
ourselves up to cover that story I'm
gonna say it
we won two Pulitzer Prize covering that
story and I think we covered that story
better than anybody else but then the
model report came out and it turns out
that none of it ended up being a thing
and then he says that we have to shift
he says I think we've got to change the
times must now write more deeply about
the country race and other divisions he
says I mean the vision for the coverage
for the next two years is what I talked
about earlier how do we cover a guy who
makes these kinds of remarks how do we
cover the world's reaction to him how do
we do that while continuing to cover his
policies how do we cover America that's
been become so divided by Donald Trump
no guys there's no such thing as media
bias that's just the executive editor of
the nation's foremost newspaper talking
about shifting his coverage from Donald
Trump's a Russian spy to Donald Trump is
a vicious KKK like racists dividing the
country why are you why do you think
there's media bias again what are you
suggesting there's media bias Madame how
dare you now why does this happen
this happens because these staffers
inside the New York Times would like to
pressure the people at the top how do
you know this because the transcript has
been released so the staffers were
asking but Katt why they don't just call
Trump racist every day and maquette was
like yeah you know maybe we should he
says you know we shouldn't use racially
tinged or racially charged he says if
you're gonna do what I said you got to
put your money where your mouth is and
just describe it and then a staffer said
quote I have another question about
racism I'm wondering to what extent you
think that the fact of racism and white
supremacy being sort of the foundation
of this country should play into our
reporting just because it feels to me
like it should be a starting point you
no like these conversations about what
is racist what isn't racist I just feel
like racism is in everything it should
be considered in our science reporting
in our culture reporting in our national
reporting and so to me it's less about
the individual instances of racism and
sort of how we're thinking about racism
and white supremacy as the foundation of
all the systems in the country and I
think particularly as we are launching a
1619 project I feel like it's going to
open us up to even more criticism from
people who are like okay well you're
saying this and you're producing this
big project about it but are you guys
actually considering this in your daily
reporting so in other words the
foundation of every story written by the
New York Times according to this unnamed
staffer is that white supremacy lies at
the root of America not the Declaration
of Independence not the Constitution of
the United States not broader principles
but racism but the story of America is
the story of racism and how racism hit
affects everything and baquette says
pretty much that he agrees with this he
says maybe we shouldn't use the word
racist because everything is racist he
quotes a guy named Keith woods whose
Ombudsman for NPR and he says his
argument boils down to this pretty much
everything is racist his view is that a
huge percentage of American conversation
is racist so why isolate one comment
from Donald Trump I do think that race
has always played a huge part in the
American story and I do think that race
and understanding of race should be part
of how we cover the American story
sometimes news organizations sort of
forget that in the moment but of course
it should be I mean one reason we all
signed off on the 16:19 project and made
it so ambitious and expansive was to
teach our readers to think a little bit
more like that because that's the job of
a newspaper is to indoctrinate you in
particular political points of view
using their news coverage man oh man I
mean that is that is astonishing stuff
from the New York Times but only
astonishing if you've never actually
watched the coverage from the New York
Times already time for some mail bagging
so let's do it
Carlos says hey Ben I'm a free-market
guy but recently I've been doubting the
validity of the claim that wages reflect
a person's productivity I'm 23 I have a
pretty high salary for my age I have a
bachelor's in economics I'm proficient
in two programming languages the thing
is I don't really do anything
I work in an office and watch videos on
YouTube most of the day I have a friend
that nurses in intensive care that makes
twenty thousand dollars less than I do
my question is is the free market really
that good at determining wages if it
were true shouldn't all the people I
know that have real jobs make more than
I do know
Carlos here's the problem you're mixing
up the value of your labor with the with
the effort of the labor the you're sort
of using a model of the the Marxist
labor theory of value meaning that how
hard you work should be reflected in
your wages as opposed to the value of
your work reflected in your wages so
presumably the reason that you are
earning more than your friends who are
nurses who work in intensive care is
because you have a very specialized
skill set that you have spent a lot of
time cultivating and there's a demand
for that skill set and so you're getting
paid more meaning that somebody needs to
do that job they're not that many people
who can do that job you are one of the
people who can do that job and so what
determines wages is not how hard you
work there are people who are working in
digging ditches every day who work a lot
harder than I do and I'm sure I get paid
more than most of those people okay but
that isn't because I have a specialized
skill set that people want to hear from
now does that mean that my work is quote
unquote
more valuable on a moral level no of
course not of course not
my wife's work is much more important
than mine on a moral level my wife is a
doctor she takes care of people she
makes a lot less money than I do right
and she's doing much more valuable work
in terms of societal influence she's
doing much more valuable work in terms
of helping people but that's a moral
judgment not a judgment as to what the
value of her work on an economic level
is now the reason that people mix these
two things up is they think okay well
that's not fair
your wife is helping people and you're
not helping as many people on a direct
level right but the answer is that if
you want more people who are doing what
my wife does then you actually need to
incentivize them to do it and also that
is determine by how many people can do
what my wife does right this is the
problem with teaching for example so
people say teachers don't get paid
enough and the answer is teachers very
often are getting not getting paid
enough and in many cases they're getting
paid too much because it's not a free
market system the question is how many
people can fill that slot how many
people can do that job the question is
not what is the inherent moral value of
the job because there is no way to
determine what somebody should be paid
based on the inherent moral value of the
job my wife should be paid infinity
based on the fact that she saves lives
but infinity is not an option the
question is how do you create a system
where a lot of people are going into
medicine to help people while also
recognizing
and not everybody should go into
medicine because it a certain point
you're gonna have a surplus of doctors
or a surplus of nurses the way that
markets determine how much labor is
necessary is through the pricing
mechanism that is what the pricing
mechanism is designed to do and this is
just as true in labor and services as it
is in product I think just on a pure
level stethoscopes more important than
pencils stethoscopes are more important
than pencils but the question as to how
many stethoscopes should be produced in
how many pencils should be produced and
that's a question of how many people
want to buy stethoscopes and how many
people want to buy pencils that's how we
allocate the amount of labor that should
be designated for a particular task and
this is why baseball players get paid at
lots and lots of money because they have
a very specialized task and a lot of us
want to see the best baseball players
but there are very few people who can
play baseball at that high a level and
so they're paid a lot of money that's
not a problem with the market maybe
that's a problem with our priorities
maybe we ought to make a case that our
priorities ought to be different but
that's a case for individual human
beings and forcing people to quote
unquote have different priorities is a
mistake because people's priorities are
what they are
Kotori says do you have any favorite
documentaries the I was first of all Ken
Burns's Civil War documentaries are
really really good Grizzly Man which is
a documentary about a guy named Timothy
Treadwell got eaten by a bear by Werner
Herzog is really good also not only is
it good also it has Werner Herzog
narrating which is always somewhat
hilarious ah when they cellies man's
enemy nature he goes out to see the
Bears butts the bears do not see him the
same way they see him as food he saw
them as friends
it's pretty fantastic other
documentaries there's one that just came
out on HBO called the cold blue that is
that is very good about flyers during
World War two
Peter Jackson just came out with a
fantastic documentary where we went back
and recolor eyes dand and put sounds
into a lot of the old footage from World
War one and called they shall never grow
old and it's fantastic yeah they're
they're a bunch of great documentaries
out there Justin says hello all mowing
Shapiro well thank you I had a question
I'd like to ask I'm 20 years old and in
college I'm wanting to dive deeper and
know more about the current issues going
on today but wanting to get multiple
viewpoints on those issues so I can hear
what both sides think what are some ways
you would recommend going about finding
info on issues from both sides while
still trying to get accurate
tails Thank You Justin well I've always
said that you should think of news
coverage as a series of intersecting
lines so if you listen to this podcast
and then you listen to the the leftist
podcast pod save America for example
you'll hear two wildly different
perspectives on the politics of the
dasie
this is also the difference between this
podcast and pod save America pod save
America will never recommend that you
listen to my podcast I'll recommend that
you listen to their podcast I don't care
I think you should I think you should
listen to lots of different podcasts
okay so pod save America you listen to
their podcast you listen to my podcast
and then what we are saying that is the
same which is usually the basis of fact
that is the intersection point
everything else is you point and that's
how you can tell right you actually have
to look at two different news look at
daily wire and then look at Huffington
Post and where they cross over that
would be the core of facts and then
everything else is opinion I've been
recommending this for years because I
think people should think for themselves
and be fair-minded and how they approach
subjects and just because something is
printed in the New York Times doesn't
make it false it may be biased in its
coverage but you have to look at how the
New York Times covers something and
National Review and what they have in
common that's probably the core of fact
and then everything else is the opinion
drawn from that core of fact Brian says
hey Ben I'm not really a question I want
to thank you on speaking I'm working
hard and not complaining it is personal
and cannot be solved by the government I
have cerebral palsy and my parents
always taught me to work hard my first
job was at McDonald's and a regional
manager said I was too slow things
worked out through hard work my brother
and I were the first to go to college in
our family I got my PhD from a top
medical research university I'm now an
assistant professor yes there are some
conservatives in the crazy world of
academia with a great salary too in
clinical work and research with over 20
publications anyone can achieve their
dreams through hard work blessings Brian
Brian I really
what a fantastic fantastic story and it
is a hundred percent true and the
decisions you make in your life are
going to impact your life way more than
anything else you do I can't tell you
the number of letters I've received this
week I mean probably hundreds of letters
this week in my mailbag specifically
about the podcasts the last couple of
days in the radio show the last couple
of days in which I talked extensively
about how it is that the personal
decisions that you make determine the
course of your life how it is not
impersonal forces that politicians blame
that determine the course of your life
that usually in a free country
the decisions you make are the ones that
are important how you problems have used
solutions and when I say that you having
two jobs to pay for a roof over your
head that's a you problem
when I
mean by that is that it is a problem for
you to solve that is not a problem that
can be solved by commonly harris riding
in on a white horse I've gotten so many
letters from people saying yeah I work
two jobs and I'm glad I do because it's
my decision and this is a free country
and a ton of letters from people who say
yeah I used to work two jobs and now I
don't have to work two jobs because I've
worked hard and I've developed a skill
set and I've made decisions and I've
moved to different parts of the country
life isn't all you're guaranteed in the
United States have said this before all
you are guaranteed in the United States
is the adventure but that's a freaking
fantastic guarantee isn't it isn't that
an unbelievably great guarantee your
grandparents from another country maybe
they weren't guaranteed that adventure
that's why they came here
you know you the people who who crossed
the continent in covered wagons and
taking months and their kids dying of
dysentery like an Oregon Trail okay
those people weren't guaranteed anything
but the adventure my great-grandparents
coming to the United States in 1907
weren't there in the guaranteed anything
but the adventure and the adventure was
the that was the point that was the
point seeing an American life as an
adventure in which you are the hero of
your own story making those decisions it
will make your life so much better than
sitting around whining to Kamala Harris
that the economy is rough right now that
ain't gonna change anything cuz Kamala
Harris ain't saving you and if you think
that welfare benefits are going to save
you either we're spending thirty
thousand dollars plus per capita on
welfare in this country for poor
families and that is not guaranteeing a
ladder out of poverty for people the
best way for you to make your way in the
world is to make a series of smart
decisions make those decisions over and
over and over learn to become the kind
of person who makes those smart
decisions you will be so much more
successful and happier in life because
you'll have taken control of your own
life and I've gotten I promise you
dozens to hundreds of letters in the
mail bag this week proving it people
saying that they actually appreciate
this perspective because there's nothing
more enervating than being told by a
politician you can't do it and the the
the Obama line the si se puede line yes
we can routine the answer is not yes we
can the answer is yes you can yes you
can it's a free country yes you can and
if you need help then reach out to a
local charity reach out to people who
want to help you to give you opportunity
I get letters every single day from
people asking for opportunities many of
them I can't
some of them I can some of them we've
hired we've hired people based on this
sort of stuff if you are constantly
seeking opportunity and taking advantage
of opportunity your life will be so much
better and so much happier and Brian
that's an amazing story and thank you
for that story as I say I wish I could
read all the letters I've gotten this
week their fans have showing them to my
wife last night and she was crying I
mean they're it's amazing there's so
many people who who are inspiring
stories of how America still works Zach
says Ben I'm trying to study the ancient
Greek philosophers I'm wondering if
there are any introductory books you
could recommend that help explain Plato
and Aristotle ideas well I mean first of
all there there are some very good
translations there's an excellent
there's an excellent what is it in
harvey mansfield translation of plato's
republic that is really really
first-rate there is also an excellent
translation available of Aristotle's of
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics there all
these translations are available if
you're just looking for sort of a brief
overview then there is a book by will
durant they called the story of
philosophy that's great it gives you
like 15 to 20 page introductions to each
of the great philosophers there's also a
great compendium called history of
political philosophy edited by Leo
Strauss that gives you 20 to 30 page
summaries of philosophy there's also a
great book called the passion of the
Western mind that really spends some
heavy time going through Plato and
Aristotle it's really good if you want
like a very very brief intro in my book
the right side of history does cover
some Plato and Aristotle right at the
very beginning talking about the
foundations of Greek thought so those
are a few recommendations Moran says how
do you think you'd fare on Jeopardy
don't be modest so the answer is I would
not fare great on Jeopardy because all
the categories in which I know a lot of
things are the categories they don't
quit on Jeopardy so it depends on how
how okay so great story okay so here's
the thing my dad was on Jeopardy so many
many years ago like 30 years ago my
father was on Jeopardy and he made a
mistake so the way that they do the
seating for Jay actually see Jeopardy
sometimes you're watching jeopardy and
when you watch jeopardy you are saying
to yourself I could answer every single
one of these questions these people seem
like dullards I could answer every one
of these questions and sometimes you're
watching like oh my god who are these
people
this is unknown the answers to this
that's deliberate so what they do is
there's first an entry test to Jeopardy
at least this is the way it worked 30
years ago men there's a secondary
in which they test you again and they
don't tell you what the test is for but
test what the test is for is to seed you
like in the n-c-double-a rankings so if
you are really really smart then they
put you with all the other smart people
in that pool so my dad passed the entry
level and then on the second level he
did the the secondary kind of quiz and
he came out and he said to somebody that
the person said how did you do so I blew
it out huh you're an idiot she's stupid
why would you do that
naturally they proceeded to see my
father against the three-time champion
of Jeopardy and a professor from
Princeton or something and my dad
actually performed pretty well my dad's
a smart dude and he performed pretty
well he was in second place going into
Final Jeopardy and second place on
Jeopardy was a trip to Mexico City and
third place was a refrigerator and my
mom was sitting in the audience rooting
for my dad to lose because they needed a
refrigerator who the hell needs a trip
to Mexico City in 1982 so my dad gets
the final question he blows that my mom
is super excited because now she has
referred that for refrigerator was in
our house for a solid 15 years how would
I do on Jeopardy so it depends on the
category so if it's a classical music
category I do fairly well it's a
baseball category I would do pretty well
if it were any sports category I would
do pretty well if it if it's a if it's a
pop culture category that's not movies
if it's like modern music or something
I'm dead in the water
I got nothing I got nothing for you
beyond like 1925 in modern music maybe
Gershwin that's it so it really depends
on the category also there's a mechanism
on Jeopardy that locks you out so a lot
of it's about the timing this is why you
see people who are returning champions
who do really well because if you buzz
in twos you have to wait for the
question to finish before you hit the
buzzer if you buzz in too soon they lock
you out so that kept happening to my
father so a little bit of Jeopardy
insider ISM they I don't think I would
do great on Jeopardy I'll be honest
Theodore I don't know a lot of the
answers but again really depends on the
seating really depends on the categories
Theodore says Haven I'm a long time fan
and a new subscriber I've heard you make
a few Mean Girls references along with a
few other pop-culture references that
sound a bit surprising coming out of
your refined mouth what are your other
guilty pleasure comedy movies keep up
the good work I think I've answered this
before but Tommy Boy is one of the great
comedies of all time
okay I'm gonna let you finish but
tommy-boy
is fantastic so the first time I told
that to my parents they were like oh
let's watch it and then they thought I
was an idiot because tommy-boy is an
incredibly stupid movie and yet and yet
it is also a fantastically wonderful
movie with Chris Farley and David Spade
it's just it's glorious I'm laughing
just thinking about Tommy Boy
fantastic other guilty-pleasure comedy
movies rat race is really underrated rat
races hysterically funny it's I have
three younger sisters my my the one
who's the oldest this was her favorite
movie growing up it was she loves
physical comedy and rat race is full of
it okay I sure uh says do you think it's
irresponsible for a young couple to get
married before they can be financially
responsible for themselves no I don't I
think that getting married is a smart
thing to do because what you don't want
is to not get married and then get
pregnant so when you're saying a young
couple to get married
it depends what is the alternative is
the alternative that you are sleeping
together and living together and then
getting pregnant without being married
because this seems a lot more
irresponsible to me if the alternative
is that you don't get married and you're
not sleeping together until you are
financially prepared then that seems
fairly responsible to me that you should
be able to have money but I also if you
have any level of income if you're
living on your own and your potential
spouse is living on their own and you
both have jobs it's cheaper to live
together than it is to live separately
you're saving on rent so I've never
really understood the argument that it
is expensive to get married not unless
you have a big wedding it ain't my wife
and I spent less money after we were
married than before we were married so
I'm not sure that I buy the argument
that marriage is some sort of financial
burden
unless one person intends on not working
and if one person intends on not working
then maybe you should wait to have kids
until you can financially afford it Joel
says hey Ben I really love the show and
value your insights if you had to guess
how probable do you think it is we could
have a crash of the US dollar at some
point over the next ten years or so if
this happened what do you think things
would be like considering that world
markets are so much more connected now
than they were before the Great
Depression
thanks well I think it's unlikely that
the u.s. dollar is going to crash over
the next ten years I think over the next
30 years the chances are fairly good but
the fact is that over the next ten years
I do not see an economic power that is
capable of rivaling the United States
the faith in the US dollar and in the
Full Faith and Credit of the United
States which is what
owners backed by that faith is going to
remain extremely high because there is
no near competitor China is not a
competitor to the US dollar in terms of
a back up currency the euro has been
falling apart that is not a competitor
to the US as a back up currency in fact
the greatest challenge to the dollar as
a back as global currency is probably
crypto you know if that starts to gain a
foothold then you could see faith in the
US dollars start to wane but over the
next ten years the answer is no over the
next ten years the US dollar will remain
the global the global basis of Commerce
Lauren says dear Ben is it concerning to
you that the past two Republican
presidents have not received the popular
vote when they were first elected why is
this the case thank you Larry well yeah
I mean I'm always concerned when when a
Republican president doesn't win the
popular vote when probably King
candidate doesn't win the popular vote
why is this the case because Democrats
can easily run up big numbers in cities
that's the answer and Donald Trump is
verily very likely to lose the popular
vote in 2020 he lost it by nearly three
million votes in 2016 I think there's a
good shot that he loses the popular vote
in 2020 simply because I think Democrats
in California and New York are vastly
concerned with him being elected and are
going to show up in massive numbers in
fact I think there could be a wider
popular vote gap an electoral college
gap than there was last time I think
it's quite possible that Trump wins the
same states that needed last time but
loses by more popular votes because
people in big cities on the coast show
up to vote but Trump already lost those
states he doesn't care the Electoral
College is not a popular vote system I
think that as the gap grows between the
popular vote and the electoral college
there will be a lot more kick back
against the electoral college just
practically speaking but it's more
concerning that the Republicans not seem
not to be able to make inroads in big
cities especially because population
seems to be moving more and more from
rural areas to urban areas Randolph says
hey Ben what is your take on hormonal
birth controls which don't prevent
fertilization but do prevent the egg
from embedding in the uterine wall
do you take the stance that this is the
same as abortion well it is a form of
abortion and so if if there is a pill
that does not stop fertilization this is
the the argument that I have with Newt
Gingrich so Newt Gingrich says that that
life begins essentially at implantation
that fertilization is not one life
begins implantation is that when the
when the egg implants in the wall of the
uterus that is when life begins so that
would allow some types of Plan B for
example because that just
stops the egg from being able to implant
I don't hold that view I don't see how
you could hold that view scientifically
speaking life doesn't begin with the
location of the life it begins with the
life so yes I think that plan B is a
problem morally speaking so that's that
alrighty let's do some things I like and
then we'll do some things that I hate
you know let's get things I like today
no more things I like
time for a quick thing that I hate sorry
so I am less than enthused about Stephen
Colbert as you may have noticed from
every show ever so Stephen Colbert used
to be a funny human and then he decided
that he was going to be he was going to
rival Jimmy Kimmel as woke Pope and now
we have a pope battle like they didn't
like 13th century in 13th century
Catholicism we have like a pope and in
anti Pope so Stephen Colbert is the anti
Pope so he is also completely and wildly
unfunny in terms of his politics and
completely non self-aware so let me give
you an example Stephen Colbert said on
his show the other night that president
Trump would look great if our next
president were a single-celled organism
meaning that Donald Trump is terrible he
will always be terribly actually said
this and Anderson Cooper you know George
W Bush left with low low ratings I guess
you would say or opinion polls and and
now is viewed much more different you
know research on that one I don't think
George W exactly compared to Trump yes
well sure well score IV if that our next
president is a single-celled organism
that Trump's gonna look great you know
some sort of slime mold oh yes it's a
obviously Donald Trump if he's only
great compared to slime mold or
single-celled organisms why do I point
this out I mean it's typical nonsense
from Colbert because then Colbert seems
perturbed that there are people who want
the president to be a complete jerk
there's a large group of Americans and I
don't even think it's necessarily
Democrat a Republican there's a large
group of Americans who think the
president should be a complete jerk he
shouldn't be somebody that you
necessarily admire it should be like
look a guy who's willing to work on the
dark side and get things done
well I also think there's people who
just like the fact that he's that you're
upset about him and that you know that
the were covering him and and drive I'm
familiar with the term drinking liberals
tears but he was like like it's a huge
price to pay
nobody's like no it's drinking leftist
years not liberals tears by the way like
we have a whole tumblr just just for it
but let me explain Stephen Colbert yes
there are a lot of people have a
gut-level reaction to jerks like you
being jerks and their answer is we
should also be jerks to you right and
and it's not something of which I
approve politically I don't think that
people should elect a president just to
drink leftist years I think it is it is
the job of conservatives to make
leftists cry with good arguments and
good policy I don't think it's the job
of the of the right to make the left cry
simply by trolling them however do I
understand the the emotional the
emotional response to Stephen Colbert
you bet your ass I do the fact that
Stephen Colbert says the kind of stuff
he says on a nightly basis is excused
for up by the media is brought on
Anderson Cooper to laugh about it the
fact that he does that sort of stuff and
then he is perturbed when people react
to him is supremely disingenuous because
this is what Stephen Colbert's let's be
real about this donald trump was elected
to be a late-night host okay that's
exactly what happened donald trump we
can talk about policy all day long and
yes some people voted based on judges
and some people voted based on pro-life
positions and a lot of that is true but
the chief appeal of donald trump as
opposed to any other republican was that
he is a late-night host who is going to
slap stephen colbert that was the but
that was the feature not the bug and
that is because when you crap from great
height upon a huge majority of the
american people it turns out some of
those people are not going to like it
very much and they're going to want
someone who slaps at you on a regular
basis you cannot simultaneously suggest
that donald trump is comparable to a
single-celled organism or or slime mold
and then be like what why are people so
angry at me all the time why do people
constantly want to comment why do they
care if Trump rips at me because you're
featured in the media because you are in
fact a person who gets an awful lot of
media attention it's amazing to me that
the left has no self awareness about
this like none
maybe you're part of the problem guys
maybe you're part of the problem did it
ever occur to you that after spending
eight years trolling Republicans as
racist sexist bigoted homophobes and
calling Mitt Romney the most boring
person who has ever lived a racist
sexist bigoted homophobe that the right
might say you know what screw those guys
elect the middle finger that that's
exactly what happened here and the fact
that Colbert doesn't even understand
this is part of the continuing problem
okay we'll be late we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours
otherwise have yourself a wonderful
relax nice weekend and then we'll be
back here on Monday to go over whatever
the hell happens this week and I'm sure
it'll be great given the last few news
cycles I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 on the mat wall show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you